Quite a few times when
I've been standing at a bus stop
people have given me money,
mistakenly thinking
that I was begging
rather than just waiting on a bus.
I was eight months pregnant,
I was in the street
and somebody stopped me
and pointed out I was pregnant.
They then said to me,
"How did you get pregnant?"
So I did end up saying,
"I had sex with my husband,
how do you think I got pregnant?"
There are so many times when members
of the public come up to me and you,
don't they Ogg?
And you look at them don't you?
So I'm like what is she doing?
What is she looking at?
Is it something that I have
to be alert and aware of?
I feel so bad sometimes saying,
"Please don’t do that."
but it is really unhelpful.
For many people disability can seem
to be a complex thing to talk about.
Perhaps they fear saying the wrong
thing or seeming patronising.
Two thirds of us are uncomfortable
when talking to disabled people
according to a survey done
by the disability charity Scope.
A disability can be a broad range
of physical conditions,
chronic health problems
and mental health issues.
Some disabilities are clearly visible
while others can't be seen.
No!
I don't suffer from my disability,
rather I live with
or have cerebral palsy.
Saying a disabled person
suffers from their disability
portrays quite a negative
image of a disabled person
rather than someone who just needs
adjustments or the right support
to be able to thrive.
There's still a huge amount
of low-level discrimination
that disabled people face.
So they think it's
amazing and wonderful
and aren't you incredible
because you're out and about,
not something that just should
be an accepted part of society.
And we're not all inspirational
just because we've got
out of bed in the morning.
It is actually one of the
most patronising things
for a disabled person to experience
is for someone non-disabled to come
and say, "You're so inspirational."
Because if you say "why?"
they often don't have an answer.
I'm a disabled person
not a person with a disability.
Person with a disability is often
used by non-disabled people
because they think it sounds nicer.
But actually, for me, it's society
that makes my life different.
It's steps, it's cobbles,
it's lifts that don't work.
My disability is not
a separate part of me
that I can choose
to pick up or put down.
I lost my sight six years ago.
One time I was approaching
a kerb with Olga,
she was on the pavement and I wasn't,
a gentleman came over
and gave her a stroke.
It made her stop in her tracks a bit
and I was still in the road.
Please don't distract her
because she's doing a job...
I'm not wheelchair-bound,
confined to or in a wheelchair,
rather, I just use my
wheelchair to get around.
So I'm a wheelchair user
or someone using a wheelchair.
Jokes about my speeding or whether
I've got a license are pretty weird
when you consider that my wheels
are essentially my legs.
It's not about avoiding topics
or trying to say the right thing
rather just treating people as you
yourself would wish to be treated.
Like many things in modern society
it's about asking
for a person's consent
and how they want things to go down
rather than just assuming.
Stop and think how
you talk to anyone else
and use that when you
talk to a disabled person
just listen to what they say.
What would be so great
is if people came up to me
and asked me if they
could stroke Olga.
I think it's really important
to have that dialogue between me
and the person interacting with me,
because the audible world is
so important to a blind person.
We don't need to be condescended
to or treated differently.
We need to be respected
and supported.